this is Octavia the melodic the maestro
she harnesses the power of the magic ore
into her mortal minuet using the manda
chord you can create your own songs for
Octavia to wield in battle divided into
three parts percussion bass and melody
Octavius song directly influences her
abilities with a variety of instruments
to choose from each battle will be a
unique concert of musical mayhem mallet
emits a percussive radius that attracts
your enemies causing them to attack the
source storing any damage taken it
releases back onto your enemies with
each beat drop the bass Tenno resonator
launches a roller ball that entrancing
your foes into following it blindly for
getting any aggression with the radius
of Attraction increasing with each new
follower it can also pick up mallet
creating a deadly mobile distraction
metronome grants one of four melodic
buffs dependent on timed actions to the
beat of Octavius song jump and receive
increased speed crouch and become
cloaked for a limited time fire your gun
and gain multi shot use your melee and
increase your damage pump up the jam
with amp drawing its power from the
level of sound of the environment it
provides a damage buff to Octavia and
her allies while also doubling a damage
and range of any nearby malice if music
be the food of death play on 10 Oh
you
[Music]